Bienvenue dans comment devenir un ninja par le moins ninja des ninjas
Ça te fais envie Clément ?
Aujourd'hui nous sommes sur VRNinja
VR Ninja ça consiste à quoi ?
Ça consiste à esquiver des objets
Voilà c'est un peu nul donc je propose que on se retouve demain
A plus ! Excellent
Non j'suis pas allé jusqu'au bout
J'ai pas mis l'outro comme des milliards de youtubeurs l'ont fait avant moi
Je n'atteindrais pas ce stade
*soufflement*
Donc y'a des objets qui arrivent
Comme ce counaille
Le but c'est de ne pas bouger les pieds
Au sol
Qu'on soit toujours sur la même base
Et d'esquiver les counailles
Voilà.
*bruit de counaille*
Ce qui est au level 1 est assez facile
Vu que les ennemis ont besoin de consulter Optic 2000
Tu vois un ninja il ne se concentre pas que sur sa vue Clément
Il se concentre sur tous ses sens
Si il ne se concentrait pas sur ..
*bruit de counaille*
J'ai eu de la chance
Si il ne se concentrait pas sur tous ses sens il ne pourrait pas faire ça
Put***
Ah ça commence à devenir intéréssant dans ce jeu là je vais pas vous mentir
On était AFK mais là mine de rien les ennemis ils commencent à être un petit peu vénères
On peut parler de munitions illimitées effectivement
Bon Ninpo trouver l'arme sans la vision
Ah bah elle marche bien cette technique
Ah grosse technique
Voilà c'est une technique que j'ai développé en 1 minute
Bon voilà on est level 4
Non mais regarde t'as déjà vu des ennemis viser aussi mal
Franchement
Ooooh attention là-bas ils sont énervés à droite
Ohf je l'ai pris pfff bullshit
Ohla ohla ohla ça commence à être ..
A bouger beaucoup là
Ohlala j'aurais du m'étirer les lombaires Clément hein
Alors je suis face à un problème que beaucoup de ninjas ont j'en suis sûr
Euh la démangeaison
A cause de ce tissu de merde
Pas du tout fait pour coller à la peau
Vague 5 sur 10 Clément
On dirait vraiment que j'suis un ninja
Si si le montage à été bien fait
On aura vraiment l'impression que j'suis un ninja
Alors qu'en vrai qu'est-ce que je suis Clément ?
Qu'est ce que je suis à tes yeux ?
"Un guignol"
Pardon ?
Ninpo la paralysie à vie
Oh put***
*bruits de counailles*
Put*** c'est lent
Franchement j'ai presque envie de passer en phase de yoga
Ahhhh j'suis en train de purifier mon nez là Clément
C'est un lieu sans pollution
Oh y'a des bombes qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Attends j'arrête tout de suite mon yoga là
Oh oh oh oh la sérénité coupée par les bombes
C'est des bombes de counailles mec ?
Ah d'accord
On part vraiment là dessus
On emploie vraiment des moyens pareils
Elle est bien triste leur vie
Ah mais d'accord faut que j'esquive les counailles qui partent de la bombe
Eh mais c'est chaud mec
*explosion
Pfff
On aurait un début de crise d’épilepsie
Ahahahah
Starting wave 7 sur 10
Alors là ça met les counailles comme ça les bombes et la totale c'est ça ?
Ok c'est esquivé
Elle est où la bombe ? Elle est là faut que j'esquive Clément
*explosion*
Voilà. C'est grâce à mes deux doigts ça hein
Attention esquive à la Matrix t'es prêt ou pas ?
Mon dieeeu
Il est fort ce Lucas
Esquive sur un pied
Incroyable
Chut un peu de silence s'il vous plaît j'aimerai méditer niveau 8 sur 10
Et ouais parce que j'ai mis un peu de Mennen au bout de mon stick ce matin
Et merde game over
Noooon mais noon
Mais c'était un placement de produit Mennen et vous me faites ça sans déconner
On peut plus gagner sa vie en 2016
Bon ce que je te propose c'est l'arcade mode
Mode arcade on a 5 vies
Et là je pense qu'on va se faire enchaîner de partout mon pote
Oook le premier qui lance le counaille il vise bien déjà c'est te dire
Le deuxième aussi c'est te dire
*rot*
Ah mais ils visent tous bien 100% de précision
Donc la bombe aussi ?
*explosion*
Non la bombe non
Ahah les bombes non elles veulent pas c'est drôle hein
Je sers à quelque chose j'ai l'impression de vraiment être le maître de ce dojo
Et de montrer à mon disciple comment esquiver ces counailles et les attraper
Attends y'a une .. whaow whaow
*explosion*
Mais qu'est ce que .. What
Qu'est ce que tu veux que je fasse la bombe elle est à mes pieds
Elle est a mes ieps
J'esquive
Ah un bol de ramen
Whaow
Oh c'est incroyable
Je viens de vivre une expérience exceptionnelle Clément
J'ai toujours pas fais l'amour mais l'expérience était bonne hein
En fait j'ai pris un ramen et ça à tout mis au ralenti
Pourquoi je t'explique ? Je m'en bats les cou*** que tu vois pas
Whaow
Put*** mec c'est chaud
Eh là faut être à l'a .. Whaow Oh j'ai failli me péter la nuque
Pas la nuque non c'est là que j'ai eu mal
Ahhhh
Ah la lombaire
Ahh repos infini
Réapparition
Ah pfiou ça va mieux
J'ai mis au point une salle où en fait une année dans cette salle c'est une seconde ici
Et j'ai pas copié DBZ (Dragon Ball Z) hein
Pffouh c'est parti là j'vais pas te mytho mec j'vais tout esquiver
*bruit de counaille*
Attends qu'est ce qu'il se passe là Clément ?
On reconnaît pas une petite technique là avec ces james
Est ce qu'il y aurait pas la petite technique grenouille du *explosion*
Ah merde
Du ping-pong là qui refait son apparition
*bruit de counaille*
Whaow whaow whaow whaow whaow whaow ah !
Mec mais c'est impossible des fois
Faut esquiver esquiver l'esquivance et la lombaire cassée
Ça c'est gratuit
C'est quoi ça ? Ah put*** mais là y'a pas le ..
*bruits de counailles*
Ahh mais c'est un truc de ouf là mec tout ce qu'il se passe à la seconde
Non non non
Ah
Ah d'accord ça envoie des fusées on part sur un 14 juillet
Oh put*** elles elles te .. oh mais
Mec j'me suis fais enchaîner plus qu'au ping-pong
Tu pensais ça possible ?
Moi non plus vraiment pas
Tu vois le traumatisme dans ces yeux ?
*caque qui tombe*
Tu peux racheter un casque s'il te plaît ?
Lui il l'a vu le traumatisme j'peux te dire qu'il l'a vu
Ninpo repos éternel
Technique que j'ai mise au point quand mon fils m'emmerdait pour jouer aux jeux vidéos
Ok on est maintenant sur un jeu très peu connu : Fruit Ninja VR
Lol
On va partir sur un arcade là je vais te montrer une technique très simple
Tu prends l'épée comme ça et tu ..
Pfffiou
Voilà
Go !
Pfff mec premier mouv que je fais je pète une bombe quoi
Gros bolosse
Ahhh
Mais mec c'est jouissif
Attends mais c'est génial
Mais les bombes par contre c'est super chaud à esquiver
C'est plus dur que sur la version mobile j'vais pas te mytho
Oh y'avais une banane bleue !
T'as déjà vu une banane bleue ?
Moi non plus
En fait t'as vu je fais ça qu'à un sabre
Voilà j'suis pas du tout ambidextre
J'suis le ninja le moins ambidextre ambidestre ambid.. ambid..
En bide j'ai fais un bide
Malaise TV
C'est pour toi
Que j'fais tout ça
Ah j'ai fais pété une bombe
J'aimerai bien faire une rangée parfaite
Tu sais genre quand je dégaine
Je dégaine et je fais une rangée
Non nul
Poooow
Et si je fais juste des petits coups ?
Ça marche pas mieux ?
Tu sais comme un cuisinier
Tu sais quand il coupe une carotte comme ça
Et toi t'as jamais réussi à faire pareil
Voilà pourquoi je parle autant de carottes ?
Je crois que ce ping-pong m'a vraiment traumatisé
Ah tu vois je retire juste délicatement la peau
J'ai pas vu mon score mais je sais qu'on va faire mieux
Vraiment t'sais en mode Etchebest
Etchebest il ferrait comme ça
Hop hop
Des petits coups comme ça très fins très rapides
Hop hop hop hop hop hop
Ça marche trop bien mec
Ah par contre t'as vu si tu tapes avec le dos de la lame ça renvoie le fruit
Ah non ça le coupe aussi .. Théorie de merde
Et si tu fais ça
110 on a fait
Quel est le classement mondial ?
*reniflement*
C'est un sketch ?
Attends il vient de quel dojo ce mec ?
Mec le deuxième mondial il a fait 560 le premier il a fait 4300
Mais c'est un dojo privé je crois
Ça ça doit coûter cher à l'année ça
Pfffiou c'est la dernière qu'on fait
Concentration
Oui c'est bien ce que vous pensez
C'est parti
Je sais je sais que c'est pas viril
Mais j'te jure c'est pour une bonne cause
J'veux aller dans le dojo de mes rêves
Mouah ah ah ah
Ah ah
Alors est-ce qu'on a battu le record ?
Et bah mec tu sais combien on a fait ?
On a fait 1050
On a battu notre record
Et milieu 2017
Quand vous voudrez faire vos inscriptions APB
N'hésitez pas à vous inscrire pour mon dojo
Je vous accueillerais les bras ouverts
Mais par contre vous aurez pas de salaire pas de futur euh rien
Ninpo vêtements de civil
Ah
On est mieux tout de suite
Bah la ceinture quand même Ninpo
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
La dernière fois on était un joueur de ping-pong
Là on était un ninja
Mais jusqu'où allons-nous aller ?
Aller à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé portez-vous bien
Ciao tout le monde